YaYeet, @AlphaPlayer23 Twitter. (This is a cool dude. I don't really know, I just went to subtitle this and that was there)
Damn I could really use a snack right now. How about you? If you clicked on this video
I'm sure you must be hungry. Hey, what's that send you a value pack see but I'm not just hungry for anything
I want that rare snack that precious tasty taste that no one else has ever tasted
Oh, I could tell you why you know what? I'm hungry for. I think you're gonna like this. Okay. How about this?
forbidden
Strawberry ice cream when you see it, it will blow your mi(laughter)nd
Not just from tasting it but looking at it
This one legit took me awhile cuz I don't get it. Oh my god. I WaNt To EaT iT. It lOoKs dEliCiOuS
You're not feeling a dessert? Okay. Alright. I understand me neither. Sometimes you just want something ehhh
ehh is a sweet  that isn't necessarily ice cream. I got you fam (why thankyou ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) )
Only ten sweet calories one sweet juicy choice. How about some gummy bears? (No thank you (;  )
num num num num o: I made so num num num num num
Still want them give them to me, give them! I know there's soap, but I still want them in my mouth.
What do you not understand? I know eating them will probably kill me, but I still want to put them in my mouth
What's so hard to understand about that! ):< the real forbidden snacks?
I mean, not if you're a youtuber you can afford it even me
I'm like nah, no, they overcharge it and I will not do it another forbidden ice cream, okay
Alright, what could it be? It looks delicious!!! (NANI?!)
Darth Wader's(lol wader xD) scalp. Yes. I do want to eat it. Why do you have to judge me for it? grr
don't you just hate when you're eating your favorite snack and then someone else comes in and be like zzz and you're like
Schut de fvf up!  (Follow @Alphaplayer23 Twitter .3.)
Somehow they have soand your meal with their judgement. It's like they spit in it. Come on stay for dinner. We're having spaghetti
Well, if your wife made the sauce I'm staying. I remember when I was younger
I would eat noodles when I came to home and my dad would he would smell it and he would go U g H
Why do you eat that garbage and I'm like, but it's delicious (Yeah. It is >;c hecin normies, ya get me fam?)
But you just took away at least two points on the delicious scale
Because of your judgment and I want you to eat the skull of Darth Vader
Then I don't need your judgment
2018 PewDiePie everybody what has happened fisherman buddy of mine found this magical guy
No eating him. It's forbidden. So yes, sometimes I guess you get these super rare. What does it call mutants, or..?
Yeah, okay, and you're not supposed to eat them because they're so rare, but whenever anyone tells
Don't eat it. My brain just goes. Oh
Yeah
so
By saying I shouldn't eat it. I
Want to eat it more it's blue. It probably tastes like bubblegum blue is color of bubblegum (wot pewds I only know pink bubblegum)
It's a bubble gum Lobster bubble gum lobster bubble gum Lobster
I don't care if I'm not supposed to eat. This is a no-judgment zone in this channel. We're an all-inclusive Channel
No judgment, aloud forbiden bacon everybody. Damn you ever cut down a tree and just go
You ever slice a tree in the many slices and
oh excuse
Excuse me, mr. Tree but
I didn't know you look so delicious. You can taste it through the screen. I
Want to eat you tree now, I don't know if it's nearly approaching dinnertime
But I'm getting hungry a swimming banana
Dang (DEMONITIZED)
Oaw That's a GOOD banana dang usually, you know people use bananas in some sort of sexual way, now that's sexy ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Okay, I want that in my mouth  (Thats what she said omgxDsofunny)
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) slurpslurpslurpslurp
Still looking for a snack still looking for something to quench your hunger all this works making me really hungry
I know just the thing. Have you heard of forbidden tuna? That's right everybody
It's me. You crack open this can of tuna. You got a 100% chance of not surviving. I like those odds
That's what makes it forbidden. And that's what makes it so damn delicious
Can you imagine the tuna that no one has ever eaten that's gotta be so good. Are you still hungry?
Okay, let's keep going guys
I put an orange on my cat and now it looks like an egg and now I want to eat it. So
It's a cat and an orange, but does it taste like egg?
Cuz it looks like egg many much tastes like trying to wrap my head around this but it doesn't make any sense
Cats don't lay eggs. I don't understand this ain't it. Which way do you like them, Jamie?
Grandville? (idk speak up kid)
Another dessert terra-misu
MmM! that looks good. That looks very good
What's that? It's about a thousand times. My size has that ever stopped me. I could just have a slice
I don't need the whole thing
All right. I know why it's too big for me. But I'll just have a tiny little piece of it
Forbidden this one is classified as forbidden. That's how you know, it's gonna be
Forbidden ground beef. I
Actually thought it was-- red mop! That must be the flavor of the beef red mop. A mop flavored beef
I know it's a mop. Okay, don't get me wrong here. I'm not stupid (no it beef. u just dum dum pee pee poo poo head. I'm just kidding I'm sorry man.)
I know it's a mop. But does it taste like beef? Hey, where's the baby? Okay, I get it
You're not into desserts. Okay, you're not into actual food. Okay, you want a snack?
You just want a snack. I got you fam. I got you. How about some Cheetos but
Forbidden Cheeto, oh
Dang(Christian Server) that
It's a Chinese cheeto. Ha ha ha ha ha (so funny). Dang. That looks good
Mmm, even the dog he's giving me that look, isn't he he is like here buddy
You've done a lot for me
You can have a bite like one or two bites, that's it  I want it in my mouth( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°). I'm not gay
All right, but I want that dog's leg in my mouth. All right,  you're a- you're a tough one to convince
All right, so no snacks. No desserts no meals. How about just a simple soup, huh?
Just a simple soup, but of course, forbidden suit. That's right. How about
Listen, you don't know if you like it. Unless you've tried it. How are you supposed to know?
I think it's really rude for people to disseminate against others. All right, just eat him
Stop being so racist just eat it. I'm getting really sick. I'm not finding the right food that I want to eat
Just want a food. I just want to food that's forbidden
Possibly illegal and most hundred percent certain they will kill me. Is that so hard to understand? All right
Okay, fine. How about forbidden Koh, how about some forbidden toast it?
Probably is (a rock)Iraq!! It weighs just like a rock. It feels cold like a rock
It is surrounded by rock, but it looks like a toast!!!(GRrR) How about some cheese?!?!
It will burn your face off. How about some shell? I don't care if it's Birds. What about some steak?
Here you go. Vegans have some steak
tee hee forbidden cheese steak
Forbidden broccoli. Why is all the things I want to eat?
Why are they all forbidden I guess I will not have any I guess I won't eat anything
I guess I'd rather starve. It's not my fault that I can't control my cravings you and I, we'll forever suffer
We will never know about the wonderful taste that our buds are being denied
This is actually a tragedy. It's a sad story, but we must be strong one day
We will eat their forbidden food speaking of food FaZe
Lampshade the absolute mad lad ate a picture of my face one of the most delicious
forbidden snacks for a hundred days
Which means now I have to eat a picture of his face, yes
That is how that works smash like and I will do it in the next episode of PewDiePie. Goodbye and check out the merch O:
Limited time only meme review merch, if you're a 9 year old and you want to flex it
(DABS DABS DABS)EXTRA CLOUT!!!
Which of course you want to do link is in the description. I see you guys tomorrow. It's yummy time.
Hope you guys enjoyed this video and subtitles subscribe to this sexy beast and follow @Alphaplayer23 on twitter (don't follow, it's a trap <; )